OUR FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
WE ARE READY TO WORK TOGETHER TO
DELIVER A RESPONSE.
>> Ed: MEANWHILE THIS VIRUS IS
MAKING ITS WAY TO CAPITOL HILL.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TESTING
POSITIVE.
HE’S TESTED POSITIVE FOR THE
CORONA VIRUS AS WELL AS BEN
McADAMS.
HERE IS THE LETTER SENT BY THE
CAPITAL ATTENDING PHYSICIAN ON
THAT.
THE OFFICES OF ATTENDING
PHYSICIANS IDENTIFY THE OFFICES
AND LOCATIONS THAT WERE FOUND TO
BE AT RISK.
THEY HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE
TREATED.
OTHER INSTANCES WHERE THE
AFFECTED MEMBERS MAY HAVE
BRIEFLY COME INTO CONTACT WITH
OTHER COLLEAGUES ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR WOULD BE CONSIDERED TO BE
LOW RISK EXPOSURES AND NO
ADDITIONAL MEASURES ARE REQUIRED
OTHER THAN FOR THEM TO REPORT IF
THEY SHOULD BECOME ILL.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE
TO 2 MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TESTING
POSITIVE AND WHERE THIS GOES
NEXT FOR YOU AND YOUR COLLEAGUES
COLLEAGUES?
>> THIS RAISES A CRITICAL ISSUE.
AFTER 9/11, LOTS OF WORK WAS
DONE HERE TO PROVIDE FOR
CONGRESS TO MEET AND VOTE HERE
SOMEWHERE OTHER THAN THE
CAPITAL.
AND THEY NEVER CAME TO AGREEMENT
ON EMERGENCY PROCEDURES THAT
WOULD ALLOW THE SENATE OR THE
HOUSE TO VOTE REMOTELY.
THAT IS NOW BEING ACTIVELY
DEBATED.
I REACHED OUT TO THE AFFECTED
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND CONVEYED
MY CONCERNS TO THEM AND THEIR
STAFF.
FRANKLY, THAT CAPITAL IS ALMOST
EMPTY RIGHT NOW.
ALMOST ALL OF MY STAFF IS
WORKING REMOTELY.
THE REST OF THE DELAWARE STAFF
IS WORKING REMOTELY.
WE ARE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND MANY ARE
SHELTERING IN PLACE AND
TELEWORKING.
FRANKLY, WE DON’T HAVE A
PROVISION THAT ALLOWS US TO TAKE
UP AND PASS SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT BILLS THAT PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES AND WORKERS
AND COMMUNITIES.
WE ALSO NEED TO PASS A BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR VOTE BY MAIL.
I’VE INTRODUCED ONE YESTERDAY.
IT’S BEING LED BY SENATOR WYDEN.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
CIVIL WAR -- IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE SECOND WORLD WAR, WE WERE
ABLE TO CARRY OUT ELECTION TO
GET BALANCE TO OUR TROOPS IN THE
FIELD AND ALLOW THEM TO STILL
LOW.
WE JUST SAW THE OHIO PRIMARY
DELAYED ABRUPTLY.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
MAKING PROVISIONS AND PROVIDING